viens nous allons passer à une autre
distraction la télévision vient du japon
nous via la télévision en boîte ou plus
précisément tout de même en mini
cassette achèteront nous un jour en
france des programmes des visions comme
on achète actuellement indice bien sûr
et toutes les firmes européennes
américaines ou treiber donc vous
présenter la solution japonaise
il s'agit en fait de transformer le
téléviseur en lecteur images la source
l'image pouvant être aussi bien une
station comme le rtf que des satellites
que des bandes que vous avez chez vous
alors voilà comment peut se présenter un
tel appareil et il s'agit ici au fond de
la transposition vidéo de la mini
cassette que vous connaissez bien pour
le magnétophone et d'ailleurs il n'y a à
l'heure actuelle des conversations pour
que dans l'avenir le système cassette
mais la personne qui a choisi son
programme permis dans sa télé texte si
vous voulez et qui maintenant va la
mettre en place mais la platine est
extrêmement simple et il y a les
conversations avec des constructeurs
européens phillips et d'autres pour
standardiser à l'échelle mondiale
normaliser cette cassette comme
normaliser le disque
non ce sera diffusé au japon au mieux
dans un an et donc encore beaucoup plus
tard en france du moins pour cette
marque magnétoscope et bien cet appareil
est annoncée à 2200 francs ce n'est pas
très cher vous allez voir d'abord il
permet de voir en couleurs vous allez
voir qu'il permet de revenir en arc est
aussi sujet lorsque vous l'aurez vu deux
ou trois fois même s'il vous plaît
beaucoup ça vous suffira
maintenant est ce qu'il y aura une sorte
de devise qu'adapter on pense qu'il y
aura des sortes de systèmes d'abonnement
effectivement voyez le retour en arrière
là qui va se faire sans problème
et oui il suffit de changer la prise
d'antenne et éventuellement on peut
enregistrer
c'est quelqu'un par exemple l'intention
de regarder le journal
il sait qu'il passe à 13 heures il peut
très bien s'organiser de telle sorte à
ce que de façon à ce que cet
enregistrement se fasse automatiquement
pendant son absence si bien qu'en
rentrant dans la journée ou en fin
d'après midi
il peut très bien vous enregistrer il
joue au regard des télés midi à 15
heures effectivement mais c'est un autre
appareil qu'on conçoit du helmand et qui
permet ce à dijon du même qui a aussi
beaucoup d'autres techniques là c'est
donc une technique de bandes magnétiques
on étudie des techniques deux fils des
techniques de la graphie ce qui est
certain c'est que c'est la grande
révolution qui se prépare et la personne
a changé très naturellement son
programme elle avait le choix comme on a
le choix parmi les pistes très bien je
remercie doit maintenant passer à la
bourse de paris à vous